en este vídeo haremos un conector de
energía para nuestro arduino aquí lo más
importante a recordar es que el pin
central de nuestro conector es el
positivo así que vamos a conectar
nuestro cable rojo en el pin central
vamos a torcer un poco el extremo para
engancharlo en el pin central ya que lo
hicimos vamos a apretar el cable para
asegurarlo en su lugar y después soldar
hemos el cable para que no se mueva
usamos nuestra pinza cocodrilo como
ayuda para sostener el cable en su lugar
ahora haremos lo mismo con el cable
negro que es el negativo y lo ponemos en
el pin exterior lo enganchamos y lo
apretamos para mantenerlo en su lugar
nos aseguramos de tener una buena
conexión entre el cable y el metal y
finalmente soldamos el cable en su lugar
ya que tenemos ambos cables soldados en
su lugar tenemos que cubrirlos y
aislarlos para que no se toquen y causen
algún cortocircuito cubrimos cada
conexión con un pedazo de cinta negra
aislante y así evitaremos que se toquen
entre sí
finalmente ponemos un pedazo de tubo
termo retráctil para cubrir ambos cables
previamente aislados por separado y
usamos la pistola de aire caliente para
encoger lo de esta manera nuestras
conexiones se mantendrán sólidas
ahora vamos a insertar el soporte de
plástico por encima de las conexiones
que acabamos de hacer lo enrosca moss
para que quede en su lugar ya casi hemos
terminado con nuestro conector
tomamos nuestros cables juntos y los
conectamos en nuestra tira de energía de
5 volts asegurándonos de que el cable
positivo se conecta al lado positivo de
la tarjeta y el cable negativo en el
lado negativo de la tarjeta hacemos un
pequeño lazo suelto con los cables y
enchufamos nuestro conector a nuestro
arduino no empujamos hasta que entre
bien ahora vamos a probar si funciona lo
encendemos y al encender debemos ver que
se ilumina un pequeño led rojo y también
se enciende un red verde en nuestro
arduino aquí lo vemos y ya estamos
listos